this cameraman is panning panning is moving
the camera this way and that too often the
cameraman pans as the spirit moves him lots of
fun when taking the picture but pity the Future
audience the result of excessive planning is
usually a confusing conglomeration like this
panning is ordinarily prompted by the beginners
desire to show everything too quickly instead of
seeing everything however the audience doesn't
get a good look at anything nothing is on the
screen long enough or clearly enough if the
cameraman would take the same subject in a
series of individual shorter scenes from various
distances and from different angles the result
would be a group of related sharp undistorted
scenes like these which when combined give
the audience a much more distinct conception of
both the subject as a whole and of parts of the
subject make up your mind that you are not
going to pan unless you positively have to
you may wonder when planning is permitted
planning is permitted only when the subject
you are photographing keeps moving around
unpredictably as in the case of wildlife
sporting events whenever you cannot direct
the action or we're taking time out to move
your camera would result in missing a vital
part of a performance to make planning look
really professional keep the subject you
are following in the center of the cameras
frame as nearly as possible keep moving with
the subject if the subject stops you stop if
the subject moves in another direction
plan with the subject in that direction
however when the scene is the last in a series
of pan shots permitting the subject to move out
of the frame is often very effective if
you have trouble following a fast-moving
subject try leading the subject that is keep
an extra lot of margin in the finder on the
side toward which the subject is moving don't
ever let the main part of the subject get out
of the finder except when ending a scene again
we say don't pay none less you positively have
to even a shot of a moving object taken from
one good angle may result in a better and more
spectacular scene next to panning failure to
use a tripod is the movie novices greatest
mistake by using the tripod you may select
your scene frame and study its composition
with all the finesse of an artist no jiggling
pictures no variation of what you meant to get
and what you finally got as is likely when
hand-holding but sometimes you'll be taking
pictures you'll have no authority to direct
or shooting an action which only happens
once like this good old-fashioned scrap which
flared up because one boy fell on another too
hard a really livewire cameraman gets right
in there to record such priceless schoolboy
antics as these even though the action isn't
in the script it's in just such a moment that
the amateur is tempted to throw aside his
tripod because he can't get it set up in time
consequently he Lou his picture if he knew how
to handle his tripod its use would be no problem
here's a tip worth remembering keep the two
rear legs the same length as each other make
the forward or pointing leg an inch or two
longer than the rear legs when you finish a
scene turn the camera so that it faces the way
of the pointing leg and when you have to run
somewhere close the leg so they won't get tangled
in your own rest the upper part of the tripod on
your shoulder and you're on and when you set the
tripod down do so with a pointing leg first then
spread the rear legs back and apart when making
the leveling adjustment you need move only one
leg if you're really in a hurry just slide
over the head of your tripod or top of your
camera at an imaginary horizontal line if your
camera is straight your picture will have to be
if you intend to pan turn your camera to follow
the subject make sure the tripod head is level
otherwise your camera will tilt sideways when
you're partway around even though the camera
itself is leveled before you started to pan to
obtain a smooth pan you must keep your feet in
place just move your body above the knees as
you turn walking around your tripod will cause
a jerky pan and of course jerky pictures on
the screen every motion picture regardless of
length is made up of three kinds of scenes the
long shot of which the scene is an example the
medium shot and the close-up they are the ABCs of
movie technique if the Statue of Liberty weren't
so famous you wouldn't know that it is surrounded
by water unless you saw it at a distance hence the
importance of the long shot it not only shows
the subject but it shows where the subject is
located and what is around it it establishes the
subject to the audience this is a medium shot of
Miss Liberty showing the whole subject as close
as possible without cutting off any vital part
of it and here is the close-up it has about
the same proportions of framing as you would
use if taking a close-up of friend the head and
top of shoulders to show you the value of using
a variety of shots and making a picture we have
selected some scenes from a Victory Garden film
sent us by one of our earlier students did you
notice how nicely he established us with his
opening shot using the Victory Garden sign was
a commendable idea it helps to tell us where we
are and what the picture is going to tell us a
story about now watch notice how the cameraman
keeps working in closer to his action even to
the point of extreme close-ups in case you're
wondering there is no set order for using your
shots although it is usually best to follow the
long shot medium shot close-up procedure to start
your picture remember your audience sees only what
you shoot it cannot go in to get a better look at
a subject or move back to see what is around the
subject unless you move your camera back and forth
for instance here the cameraman wanted to show the
moving of his characters from one location to
another so he moved back to show that our route
thus giving his audience a chance to see where
the characters were going in relation to where
they had been to many close-ups in succession
caused the loss of clear-cut conception of the
overall picture it is a proven fact that
the audience seldom remembers accurately
what has been shown more than one or two scenes
back that is why it is so necessary to show a
general view every now and then such views are
appropriately called reestablishing shots just
as there is no set order for shots there is no
set length for them either once you have learned
the ABCs of it the key to successful moviemaking
is plenty of sensible variety in your technique
no screen direction in this case doesn't have
to do with directing a motion picture we'll show
you what we mean by joining this couple on their
height if they don't object well let's make up our
minds which way is it going to be it's certain if
they don't know which way they're going we won't
that's an idea let's toss for it settle so we're
going this way which way is this way in motion
picture lingo these hikers are going from left
to right they are are they in each consecutive
scene they are progressing from the left side of
the screen to the right that's screen direction
now they are moving from right to left thus
our subjects have made what we call a change
of screen direction it is now a right-to-left
screen direction because the hikers are coming
from the right side of the picture and moving to
the left but we didn't start that way remember the
toss it was determined that their course would be
this way from left to right besides if the action
were right to left now you'd feel as though the
hikers were going back to the crossroads again it
is necessary to maintain screen direction if you
want your subject to seem to be getting somewhere
if you don't observe scream direction it will
look as though the subject is merely traveling
back and forth across the screen getting nowhere
if your picture is long sameness in direction may
become monotonous so you'll have to have a change
of direction but don't do what we're doing here
whenever you put a series of scenes with different
screen directions together the result is both
frustrating and confusing whenever you start using
scenes in which the action changes direction you
must first show the change like this notice how
smoothly the action runs now that we have shown
our subjects turned and go the other way you may
change screen direction as often as circumstances
and the flow of your story indicate as long as you
show the actual changing everyone is familiar with
fact that a motion picture is made up of a series
of scenes which when put together tell a story or
relate a complete episode of action as shown
in lesson three there have to be long medium
and close-up shot so that the audience will get a
comprehensive look at things this means the camera
is placed in a different location each time a
scene changes yet in spite of all these scene
changes the subject action must flow continuously
as though the scenes were all taken from one spot
and the camera had never stopped you saw the
subject arrived with a radio tuned in and go
into her exercise every move that she's made
since you first saw her has been shown to you
as an unbroken flow of action but do you realize
how many times the action was broken while the
camera was being moved to each new location
for each scene that you are seeing unless due
care had been taken to keep every detail of the
subjects position the same at the start of each
new scene as in the end of the preceding scene
this smooth continuous flow of movement could
never exist so matching action you see insofar
as the cameraman or his assistant is concerned
is a case of remembering details as they were
in the completion of every scene if we hadn't
carefully noted this young lady's posture each
time we stopped the camera her arms legs and the
pitch of her body certainly wouldn't have been
matching so nicely at the change of each scene
in order to let you see for yourself
how important matching action is we're
now deliberately ignoring it notice the
disagreeable jaw or jump at the beginning
of these scenes this is because you are now
in the place of the audience seeing scenes
follow each other with lightning quickness a
cameraman has a chance to forget the details
of the previous scene well the audience doesn't
have it doesn't take time out while equipment
is being moved around for the next shot in fact
the old scene is still in mind when a new one
appears that's why even a slightest variation
from matched action is exceedingly noticeable
on an amateur scale action is often that by
having a subject hold or remember the pose until
the camera starts grinding again this is known as
cutting in the camera the professional method of
matching action however is that of reshooting
the last bit of the previous scenes action at
the beginning of the new the actual matching point
is later decided upon in the cutting room by this
system action can be matched at any point where
it had been reshot once you cut in a camera you
have no future choice well lesson 5 demonstrated
that not one second of action is permitted to
be skipped at the joining points of consecutive
scenes in planned films the practice of skipping
even whole sequences of action is permitted of
necessity in the newsreel type suppose you are
photographing a ball game it's not likely that
you would want to record a play-by-play that would
take several thousand feet of film but you would
want your audience to feel that it had seen it
all so you'd probably start with some prior to the
game scenes in the manner we're showing you from
here on you shoot only the most spectacular keep
in mind that even though action may be skipped
and scenes do not have to be matched as in the
controlled action type of picture they must be
tied together sufficiently to give that feeling
of a continuous flow of action tying together
is accomplished by taking numerous cutaways
scenes shots of things and activities which
are related to the subject action in the case of
photographing a ballgame the crowds in general and
the antics of rabid fans are always good cutaway
material I together yours is the same problem so
you will want to employ the same or a similar
technique we've made kind of a running gag of
the three children the girl taking advantage
of the boys intenseness in the game to steal
as popcorn always keep your eyes open between
main events look for cutaway possibilities the
cutaway scene may also be employed to convey an
extensive lapse of time suppose the ball game you
were photographing had three very dull innings
the third fourth and fifth and you didn't take
a foot of subject action by substituting actual
action with a quick succession of scoreboard
shots numerically showing the progress of the
game through these periods your audience could
be made to feel that it had sat through the entire
action when the next bit of subject action appears
on the screen even though half an hour or more
of play had taken place the audience would be
fully oriented no how many innings had passed
and the result of each so you see no matter how
scattered your actual play-by-play scenes are
whether you want to cover up for skipping half
a minute or half an hour of missing action the
correct cutaway can make the audience feel that
nothing has been missed the final scoreboard shot
is the natural end for this picture anything that
could have been happening or existing during the
game and that has some bearing on the main action
of your picture is cut away material these extra
scenes are to show you how cutaways can be faked
admit it now you thought that these youngsters
were part of the actual crowd when you saw them
before didn't you they were never at the game
at all in every camera man's career there comes
a time when he finds himself possessing some
interesting footage which for one reason or
another is too incomplete to make a sustaining
film professionals bridge situations like these
by shooting extra scenes which build up to and
lead away from the problem scenes the result is
a complete subject methods of buildup are limited
only by your imagination this man is accomplishing
build up by sim taking shots of his boy writing a
letter and keeping the text of the letter confined
to descriptions and discussions of people things
and places contained in the Arden and movies he
had of his son a complete little film story about
a boy writing a letter to his pal is the result
this cameraman isn't taking a picture he's
feeling for one in his finder indeed feeling
is the automatic tuning medium for all
pictorial composition when you sight
through a finder you're doing a lot more than
making sure that your subject is really going
to be in the picture you're actually composing
a picture and putting a frame around it you're
doing the work of an artist at last our
cameraman seems to be coming to something
we wonder if he knows why it's promising
composition well mainly it's because he's
bringing that tree in at one side and because
of that road running diagonally into the scene
keeping foliage in the foreground is
a great aid to composition designers
of stage sets have used this technique
for ages utilizing wings on each side of
the stage to give the illusion of depth but
depth giving foreground treatments need not
always be trees notice how this arch makes
the trolley seem to come from way back in
the picture so that you're sure to feel
and see what we mean we are showing you
these scenes first without foreground treatment
than the almost identical scene with foreground
two lifeboats can be used in the foreground as
long as it's in the keeping with the mood of the
scene the barber pole in the scene you're right
with in addition notice how the diagonal line
of the elevated structure lends depth and observe
and bind as here the foliage foreground plus the
diagonal line of the fence they are especially
effective as we said composition is pretty much
a sense of feeling you wouldn't put a tree or a
lamppost in the dominant center of the picture but
Memorial or religious statuary you might a kind
of instinct tells you it's the thing to do feel
for a picture in everything you see and strive
to make your pictures portray what do you feel
whether you're going to take color or black
and white movies your first step in setting
up lights will be the same arrange two or more
reflectors so that the area you are photographing
will be lighted head-on from the direction of
the camera and so that there will be an even
quantity of light spread over the whole scene
this is called flat lighting in black-and-white
movie making a lot more is dependent upon and
may be done with lighting so we'll proceed with
lighting for black and white the second step for
lighting the average black and white scene is
to throw a more intense light in diagonally
from one side of the set being more intense
this light cast shadows and creates highlights
upon your subjects highlights and shadows in
black and white photography or what give the
all-important illusion of depth and roundness
to further the same illusion and give pictures
the true professional Sparkle we employ either
background lighting or back lighting background
lighting is the throwing of controlled light
upon a chosen area of background no part of the
REA directly touching the subject registering
an entirely separate plane of light behind the
subject in this way tends to make the subject
stand out in scenes where the accent is on
romance you'll find backlighting the second
professional treatment which we mentioned
especially pleasing but to demonstrate this
we should have a little cooperation from the young
lady remember me I'm your husband backlighting is
accomplished by throwing a concentrated light
on the subject from behind since the light is
now facing the camera care must be taken to
keep it tilted or she'll comedy and routine
scenes flat lighting will usually serve best
while for romance ha let's take another look